いつになったら国作るんですか
多分
無理ですこんにちははじめしゃちょーです
僕今までいろんなホラー企画とかちょっと
心霊系とか
幽霊的な企画をやってきたんですけども皆
様が思う一番怖いシチュエーションって
どんなシチュエーションですかもちろん
世の中にはいろんなお化け
妖怪幽霊
呪い様々なものがあるんですけれども僕の
経験上の映画とか古代が好きで結構見るん
ですけども僕が色々経験してきた中で
多分
僕が一番怖いでやろうシチュエーションっ
て車で山道というかなんか山道をこう車で
運転してる時に
運転してるこの道の先に
白い服の女の人が立っている
それが一番怖いと思うんですよ
例えばサイドミラーで見たらいるんです
けども実際に見たらいなくなってたとか
なんかそういう怖い話僕見たことあるん
ですけどもやっぱりなんかこの
白い服を着た髪の中に女性僕の中ではそれ
がすごいどうしても怖いっていう印象が
あって
昔のお化けと八尺様とか呼ばれています
けれども
普通の人間だとなかなかないような身長の
大きさだったり
異常に肌が白かったりするという今回は
そのはじめしゃちょーが描く最も怖い
シチュエーションを
山道で完全再現してビビりなターゲット
たちに実際に
ホラー体験をしていただきたいと思います
ではいこう
はいというわけで現場に到着しました
割とね結構有名な心霊スポットというか
トンネルに来ておりますよかったな今日は
仕掛け人で
割と忠実に怖い状況作りたいんで圭介は
今回ちょっとカメラとして回っていただき
ます残念ですいや残念ですね
本当に残念ですね
仕掛けたかったクオリティ重視していき
たいからマジでしっかりこの心霊スポット
トンネル付近でガチのやばいセットをして
もう身長がめちゃくちゃでかい女の人を
置いていきたいと思いますしっかりとその
幽霊とかおまけセットしていきたいと思い
ますというわけでまずはちょっと場所見て
いこうかはいここですね
うわー
[音楽]
これは雰囲気ありますねかなり
いやー
なんとなくどこに配置するかとかの考え
ながら見ていきますこれすごいね
えここメンツトンネルでしょ明治トンネル
に入る手前って感じですね
俺多分行ったことあるんだよな普通に
多分あると思うんすよさすがになんかもう
しないとかけんなよもう大体って言ってる
んですけど
そのねほんとだはい
明治トンネル
知ってる方も多いのではないでしょうか
明治トンデルって言われる静岡でも結構
有名な心霊スポットと言われてる場所です
行きましょう
[音楽]
言うねああいうのもこういうね灯篭という
かなるほどねOKOKありがとうござい
ますはいたくさんスタッフの方も来て
いただいております今回
ガチですはいというわけで一応トンネルの
中を見ていきましょうか
突然出てくるの大切だと思うじゃん幽霊が
確かに
トンネルってさ一方道だからちょっと
びっくりさせるには難しいのかなと思って
おります
来たことあるわ
ガチで嫌だもう
入りたくねー
時間健介
奥まで行ってみますかマジ
えっ
早くまで
ロケサンロケ班
声の響き方がマジで来い
まず
急いで
[音楽]
怖い怖いもう
うわびっくりしたやめてよー
[拍手]
全身鳥肌立ったからいやちょっと1本道
すぎて配置できないんだろうなあ確かに
言うとしたらこういうとこじゃないここに
さ
手立て置いてさちょっと見えそうだよね
ヤクルト中でバレちゃうんすね
やめてよもう
めんどくさいからなんで置いてくのという
わけでちょっとトンネルの線はないっすね
今回でも突然出てくるっていうのが難しい
し俺の怖い理想をシチュエーションは運転
中の
道にいるってところからちょっと今回
トンネルは無しでいきますはいというわけ
で実際に心霊スポットに着いたので
ちょっと配置する場所を決めていきたいと
思いますもうちょっと完璧に行きたい
車でこう上がってくると
車のライト多分こっちにするからこことか
ですかねー
[音楽]
スポットあるあるなんですけども暗すぎて
を映らないあるよねよくよくありますね
照明とかしっかり置かせてもらって
確実に
運転してる
ターゲットの目に入るように工夫したい
はいお願いします
[音楽]
パッと見るとさ該当っぽくこことか
絶対見えるすねそこは
徐々に微修正していきましょう今回
ターゲット3人準備してるんで
女の人が乗るような脚立ですあ来ました
よろしくお願いします
そもそも大きいよね女性の方何cm82
です
うおー
[音楽]
やばい夢で見たやつだ
1回走ってみましょうか
絶景ちょっと車で走ってみます
世界で発するね
剣士はじめしゃちょー役に俺じゃ竹ったく
ねどこ連れてくのはちょっともうすぐ行っ
てもらってちょっとまっすぐもうちょっと
あでもあんまり早く行くとここら辺の道
危ないからなるべくゆっくりめでとう
心霊スポットじゃないですかねいやもう
全然大丈夫みたいな感じで見てみようかな
みたいな回なんだけどそんなテンション
このまっすぐでこのまますぐに
なんかね今証明的にめっちゃわかり
やすかったでもえーこれめっちゃいい感じ
に映れますよ消えたんだけど
消えたんだけど今ここ見たあのなんか
わかるかなお化けとか神永い女の人の幽霊
って
髪がなんか
ゾワゾワしてるんすよ分かる健介なんと
なくあのスカートとかなんかうわーその時
はざわざわざみたいな
感じを表現したいので今回送風機も準備し
ておりますだんだんね準備今日はなるべく
脅かしたいのでそれ探そうか見たいです
みたい
どう
微風だね
これこれこれこんな
感じでこの感じわかる髪が逆立つ感じこれ
を表現したかったんですよ私なるほどなん
となくこれぐらいでいい気がするんで
ターゲット車にちょっと風で
ふわっとさせたいと思いますよろしくお
願いしますお願いします
すごい元気でいい声
[音楽]
お疲れ様です
まあ何と言わないですけど今日すごいここ
なんか焼きが綺麗な場所で
心霊スポットとしても有名なんですけど
全然そんな怖いとかじゃなくGalaxy
の案件で
めっちゃ暗いとこでも取れ
るっていうことで
うーんちょっと上に素敵な景色と素敵な
ちょっとこれでいいじゃないですけど1人
ずつ案内する
のこの
上にあのメイツトンネルと言われる
めっちゃ怖いトンネルがあるんすけどそこ
にはいー
夜空が抜けてる広場みたいなやつがあるん
でそこに行くだけで大丈夫ですやった車の
中で心霊系野党の
案件だからさすがにそういうのではない
案件で死んでは絶対やらん大丈夫けど
ちょっとテンション上げすぎると困るんで
フラットに来ていただけると一番
ありがたいので
次の夜景見に行きましょう
かじゃあおはようございます
700いきましょうお願いしますじゃあ
左の方ねはい
全然ゆっくりですよまず綺麗なんで
夜空とか好きですか
しないっすよねあの寄生してる時に
家族で行くぐらいですかねはいはいはい
ここのスキルで大丈夫ですか大丈夫です
もう全然全然
急になんか出てこないですかね
うわー
[音楽]
をお疲れさんお疲れ様お疲れ様です
弱気な感じになってるまたその声の苦手な
の無理ですね無理か
ねこんな
急に来たらもうやばいっすよ
確かに心霊スポット言ってるわけじゃない
なあんまり
行ったことないですねマジ最強初だね
近づいてきました
えちょ待って
ちょ待ってくださいって
ちょ
待って
これない
本当に怖いさこういう感じになっちゃうの
か
びっくりしたマジでまたぞ
これだけだ
2人終わったんですけれども最後の
ターゲット大作くんということでちょっと
だけ
改造したいです今まで道のこの横にいて
曲がり角にいたんですけど最後私がもう
安全安心に運転しますので
道の真ん中に立っていただこうかとか思っ
ておりますやばいよやばいよね
寒いと思うんですけど最後なんでよろしく
お願いしますお願いします
伝わりますこれこの感情をぜひとも皆さん
に伝えたいこの感じこそが
ホラーなんですこの逆立つ感じターゲット
最後思いっきり脅かしていきたいと思い
ます
太一君にはねもう最高のスペシャルアーケ
ということでちょっとすいませんね
花火とかの仕込みとか
マジかよじゃあ
行ったことあるような気がする
あれ
ごめんなさい
多分そこに
これ
回ってる今
回ってる1回止めてもう1回つけてもらっ
ていいですよ
止める
つけたありがとう
[音楽]
うわ怖い待っていいもう近寄らんといて
怖い怖い怖い怖い怖い見てこの風の感じ
本物かと思ったの
めちゃめちゃリアルじゃん
山口に寝る白い大きい女性が一番怖い説
でした
間違いないよだってどう見ても
めちゃめちゃ怖いじゃん
下から見た時に白いのが見えて
え何言ってた瞬間で
満足
はいというわけでどうだったでしょうか
あの本当に僕が一番
怖いと思ってるシチュエーションで
ドッキリさせてもらったんですけどもいい
感じにみんな
ビビってくれてめっちゃ良かったですてか
やっぱでかいのが怖いね
約3mの白いドレスを着た肌が白い女性が
やっぱ立ってると
相当分かったみたいで
満足しました今回の撮影ですね夜にしたん
ですけどもやっぱ暗くてなかなかスマホと
かで動画撮る時結構暗くて難しいんです
けども今回こちらのギャラクシーS20
ウルトラこちらですねマジですごいんです
よあのナイトグラフィーカメラって言わ
れる暗いところでもバチバチに映る
すごいカメラが搭載されておりまして今回
の撮影もかなりお世話になりました
実は車内から撮ってたカメラとか外でも
撮ってたカメラ結構これ使っておりまして
めちゃくちゃ綺麗に映ってすげえ助かり
ました
YouTuberにもかけず外で綺麗に
取りたい人とかとてもおすすめですそして
こちらさらにすごいのがSシリーズ初のS
1000内蔵モデルとなっております今
からお見せしましょうこれすごいのがここ
押すとペンが出てきて
ペン出た瞬間そのまますぐメモ帳になるん
すよこれ
すごくないすか
メモしたい瞬間って多いんでなかなかね
スマホからこうやってペン出てきてその
こうやってかけたりだとかでビデオボード
にしてですよこれBluetoothと
繋がっててペンがボタンを押すと
録画できたりするんですよめっちゃ便利
シャッターとかも切れるんでカメラで写真
撮影する時も便利ですさらにお得な
キャンペーンも実施しておりますので動画
の概要欄からチェックしてみてくださいと
いうわけでまた心霊的な怖い企画を
思いついたらやってみたいと思います
じゃあな
[音楽]